déjà nous a dit hier qu'elle était venu
vous voir pour la première fois à 17 ans
elle nous a dit qu'elle avait cherché
voilà sur google voilà une voyante et
qu'elle était tombée sur ses vraies
cette histoire exactement ça c'est vrai
dans quel verrou voir pour la première
fois à 17 ans elle avait entre 17 et 18
ans chacun de mes mars et en 2015
elle n'est pas venue me voir pour la
voyance elle est venue me voir
directement pour des travaux on appelle
ça des travaux d'accord je croyais que
vous étiez aussi dans le btp est en voie
pour des travaux c'est quoi des travaux
pour que les gens comprennent les
travaux ça peut être
envoûtement d enfouissement retouramont
heures voilà pourquoi elle se sentait
pas bien dans sa peau à la vie voilà
peut-être deux c'est quand même à titre
privé
malgré tout je peux pas dévoiler
d'accord bien sûr fois l'événement va
donc cesser c'est tout à votre honneur
c'est vrai quelles étaient vos relations
avec elle très bonne très bonne très
bonne
je n'ai jamais coupé le contact avec
carla elle n'a jamais coupé le contact
avec moi de 2015
jusqu'en janvier 2021 ce que m'a dit que
c'est vous qui nous a dit que c'est vous
qui l'avez rappelé après elles vont
l'avoir
pas du tout je peux apporter les preuves
d'ailleurs que j'ai donné il ya une
enquête comme vous le soir du 24 ans
pour donc moi j'ai apporté tout ça à la
justice ils les ont je n'ai le contact
n'a jamais été coupé entre moi et mon
ancienne cliente
non parce qu il l avait dit que vous
l'aviez recontacter et qu'elle s'était
retrouvé face à 10 personnes
absolument pas donc ça pour vous c'est
donc non d'accord non alors est ce qu'il
y ait eu quand même 7
elles veulent est venu voir la première
fois dix et ont ensuite à l'air venu
vous voir une autre fois non elle est
venue me voir donc en 2015 elle devait
avoir 17 18 ans partant de là le contact
entre nous est restée au quotidien tout
le temps ma cliente me solliciter
régulièrement pour faire appel à mes
services voient la preuve que j'ai
ouvertement donné à les enquêtes de
police
d'accord alors venez vous consulter
auprès régulièrement peut appeler ça des
consultations d'accord c'était quoi
c'était elle venait me demander des
prestations d'accord combien vous
facturer ses prestations
c'était très aléatoire série les accords
de 2 à vous demander quoi dans ces
consultations vous pouvez pas nous le
dire
non je peux pas parce que ça serait
dévoilée non je peux pas alors le vrai
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui ci est ce
qu'elle vous a pour comment on a pu
arriver à cette histoire de sorcellerie
de sort
comment ça se passe en fait parce que
nous on n'y croyait pas du tout à cette
histoire donc carla bien pouvoir et elle
à dire que vous lui avez dit que pour
pouvoir exaucer des voeux il fallait
qu'elle les formules
absolument pas
on venait me demander des prestations je
peux pas m'étaler sur ses prestations là
parce que je suis quand même tenu malgré
tout même poussé mon ancienne enseigne
clientes et il ya ce fameux sa fameuse
enquête en cours
je peux pas du tout métal et par rapport
à ça mais c'est elle qui venait me
demander un et ça j'en ai les preuves
je peux tout apporté je peux tout
justifier c'est elle qui venait me
demander
j'ai besoin que tu me fasses ça ou ça ou
ça donc comme si vous allez voir cyril
la chaleur bien esthétique vous lui
demandez je veux ça ça ça ou ça moi
j'allais pas j'allais pas lui dire oui
il fait ça vous fait ça alors parce que
là d'anaïs je sais que vous êtes tenus
par le secret professionnel mais et de
l'anc est aussi un voilà et de l'anc est
aussi mais est-ce que vous avez procédé
à la sorcellerie contre eux des
candidats de télé réalité c'est la
question j'ai procédé à de la
sorcellerie j'aime pas ce terme moi j'en
crois qu'en voilà on emploie quelques
travaux occultes d'accord troisvaux
culte
c'est à dire donc c'est des travaux pour
nuire à certaines personnes n'ont pas
forcément faire du bien aussi
on fait pas que du mal dans les travaux
puce d'accord donc là c'était pour faire
du mal il ya trois magiciens peux me
permettre
tout à fait c'est ça il ya la blanche la
rouge et la noire il ya souvenez vous
même en déclarations vous avez dit que
vous seriez jamais de la noire de la
magie noire là c'est ce que vous avez
fait visiblement si je peux me permettre
oui moi personnellement je vais pas en
faire moi tout seul si je suis c'est à
la demande de mon client ou de ma
cliente donc moi tout seul je me lève
pas un matin en me disant ok je vais
faire ça sur telle ou telle personne
on vient me demander non mais j'imagine
donc vous l'avez fait site oui je les
fais